yeah extremely painful for uh the
families the relatives the friends of
those people who have been watching this
inquiry as as the details of it unfold
uh in the state senate down in texas and
and just shockingly damning as well in
terms of multiple failures by the police
we had already had a hint that clearly
something had gone wrong on that day
because it took so long for the police
to enter the building to enter the
classroom to neutralize uh to use their
language the gunman
and we know too that the parents of
those people who were in
the school had gone down there pretty
quickly in uvalde and had tried to plead
with the police to move in but they
didn't and so an inquiry has now
unfolded and you can hear i think from
um one of those people giving evidence
who is the the texas department of
public safety director have a listen to
what he told the inquiry
three minutes after the subject entered
the west building
there was sufficient number of armed
officers wearing body armor
to isolate distract and neutralize the
subject
the only thing stopping a hallway of
dedicated officers from in room 111
and 112
was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers before the lives of children
now clearly that person who was in
charge that day has an awful lot to
reflect on it must be difficult for him
too he has been giving evidence but not
in public
in private um we know now uh that eight
minutes after the gunman uh entered the
school uh one officer uh said that he
had a crowbar which he could use to uh
get in uh through the a door uh but they
and officers instead opted to wait for
keys for that door it later um emerged
that the door wasn't even locked they
hadn't even tried to go in through the
door they assumed it was locked from the
inside and therefore were waiting for
keys 19 minutes after the gunman entered
police had in their possession a
ballistic shield with which they could
have uh moved closer to the classroom
but again they opted not to uh and 19
officers were in that hallway when the
first 9-1-1 call was made from inside
one of the classrooms and yet it took
well over an hour for them to enter the
classroom
a truly damning
set of um
of revelations that we have heard today
as i say just so tragic and so difficult
for those families as they absorb all of
this